un échange d'e-mails qui ne fait pas les
affaires de l'exécutif encore moins
celle de jérôme salomon le directeur
général de la santé au coeur de la
polémique et des e-mails que la
commission d' enquête du sénat a pu se
procurer
selon nos confrères du journal le monde
des messages de jérôme salomon pour
faire pression sur la rédaction du
rapport ce talent commandé par l' agence
santé publique france sur la situation
sanitaire française remis en 2018 ce
rapport indiquait au gouvernement la
nécessité de provisionner un milliard de
masques afin d'être en mesure de faire
face à une éventuelle crise sanitaire
il est important qu'une doctrine soit
rapidement établie par vos services pour
que les éventuelles acquisitions de
produits de santé soient mises en oeuvre
afin de disposer d'un stock avant le
deuxième trimestre 2010 9
sauf que ce rapport n'arrange pas à
l'époque les affaires du ministère de la
santé
soucieux de faire des économies en
témoigne l'achat d'un stock en 2018 par
le directeur général de la santé de
l'époque benoît valait nettement
inférieure aux recommandations des
experts
100 millions de masques seulement à
peine 10% du milliards préconisés
aujourd'hui sera postale qui avertissait
des conséquences éventuelles d'une crise
sanitaire est une épine dans le pied du
gouvernement
car loin de tenir compte des
recommandations du rapport l'exécutif
s'est au contraire échiné à en atténuer
la portée
c'est ainsi que jérôme salomon aurait
tenté par des e-mails de contraindre
l'ex directeur de santé publique france
à minimiser les risques
l'une des solutions pourrait être alors
de modifier la rédaction de certaines
formulations
ensuite il reviendra aux autorités de
définir le stock nécessaire une pression
trop lourde à supporter pour françois
bourdillon qui finira par céder quelque
temps après voilà donc en retour la vie
dans lequel j'ai retiré toute allusion à
un stock chiffres et notamment pour les
masques les 7 et 8 décembre dernier les
sénateurs ont eu accès aux conclusions
de la commission denquête et ses
dernières établissait clairement les
pressions exercées par jérôme salomon
pour modifier l'avis remis en août 2010
8 à santé publique france cette
politique de réduction des coûts à tout
prix même celui de la santé des français
ne date pas d'hier
car benoît vallet directeur général de
la santé de 2013 à 2
18 en avait déjà fait les frais face à
la destruction d'une partie des stocks
de masques et jugé non conforme
le prédécesseur de jérôme salomon
n'avait cessé de mettre en garde
l'exécutif
visiblement plus conciliant son
successeur ex conseiller santé des
manuels macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle
était-il au courant du risque de pénurie
de masques en cas de crise là encore la
réponse serait oui si l'on en croit une
note confidentielle datée du 5 septembre
2016 est adressé aux candidats emmanuel
macron la possibilité de survenue d'un
événement naturels d'ampleur avec un
impact sur grand nombre de personnes des
dommages matériels importants
un impact financier et d'image et des
capacités de réaction des passes et doit
être sérieusement envisagée est
anticipée la france n'est pas prête
notre pays doit adapter ses
organisations spécificités des crises
majeures à venir des recommandations
adressées par jérôme salomon médecins
aux candidats macron des recommandations
donc que jérôme salomon devenu directeur
général de la santé n'a pas vraiment
pris en compte
un revirement difficile à comprendre au
final dans l'esprit de beaucoup ce
rapport viendra confirmer le sentiment
d' incohérences total de l'exécutif dans
la gestion de ces fameux masque car
après en avoir considérablement diminuer
le stock
il a longtemps nié leur utilité avant de
les rendre obligatoires avec amende à la
clef pour les contrevenants face à la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
ainsi que celle du sénat l'étau se
resserre sur un gouvernement qui semble
avoir épuisé son stock d' excuses quant
à sa gestion très discutable de la crise
sanitaire